[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va se parler de son joli
petit smartphone qui est dans cette
boîte qui est là qui était dans la boîte
mais qui n'est plus dans la balle je les
prie je les sorties j'ai utilisées c'est
la raison pour laquelle il n'ya plus de
la boîte c'est celui-là c'est le week au
view 5 + rumiko je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez l'histoire d'une entreprise
qui était créée en france et qui a
regardé hier c'est bien marqué ici la
design et en france plutôt sympathique
et qui vous propose des smartphones dans
l'entrée milieu de gamme
ici on est sur un smartphone d'entrée de
gamme c'est la cinquième édition de la
gamme view le view 5 c'est le view 5
plus alors aujourd'hui ricoh présente
deux nouveaux modèles le view 5 et le
view 5 + moi j'allais view 5 plus ça
fait quelques jours que je lis avec moi
et il est temps de vous dire un petit
peu ce que j'en pense de ce vieux 5 plus
il fait des jolies promesses notamment
le fait d'avoir une grosse batterie de
5000 milles et en perd heures pour avoir
une très grosse autonomie on va regarder
si effectivement c'est le cas ils vous
proposent également pas moins de quatre
caméras que vous retrouvez ici à
l'arrière donc une configuration
intéressante on va voir si c'est le cas
et puis surtout un design qui est un
petit peu revu et notamment avec ici ce
petit poisson vous avez à la face avant
donc on va regarder tout ça on va faire
autour de ce week au view 5 plus je vais
vous dire ce que j'en pense mais la
première chose à savoir et c'est
extrêmement important sur ce produit là
c'est qu'ils coûtent un tout petit peu
moins de 200 euros 199,99 c'est très
important de le repositionner par
rapport à son prix et par rapport bien
évidemment aux tarifs de la concurrence
se passe extrêmement rapidement 5
packaging est plutôt sympa et efficace
de la part de wilko bon retrouve un peu
l'esprit qu'à l'arrière ça ça fonctionne
ce qui nous intéresse c'est plutôt ça
c'est plutôt le ce partenariat déjà
j'aime bien cette couleur avec ses
petits reflet on a des teintes un peu
violine en veille sur le côté je pas si
vous en rendrez bien content comme ça
dans la vidéo on est plus sur un espèce
vers un petit peu canard sur le bas très
sympa l'intégration est plutôt bien on a
le retour surtout du capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui avait disparu
il ya pas très longtemps qui revenue en
force sur un smartphone dans cette gamme
de prix ça me paraît aussi complètement
normal on le prend on pose son doigt et
on déverrouille extrêmement rapidement
ça marchera parfaitement le taf ya
effectivement des bords noirs sur la
face avant sur les contours et également
en bas sur ce qu'on appellera le menton
ça me paraît aussi tout à fait normal et
une fois de plus sur smartphone un tout
petit peu moins de 200 euros
donc de ce point de vue lassana conté un
truc que j'aime bien et je vous dis tout
de suite au niveau de l'intégration
logicielle c'est le fait d'avoir intégré
voyant de batteries ici là autour de la
petite caméra ça je trouve ça vraiment
très malin et j'aime beaucoup
après avoir trouvé sur le côté trois
boutons le premier bouton c'est pour
l'allumer et l'éteindre sensu
complètement d'accord ça marche bien le
bouton de volume ici bien évidemment est
tout à fait normal mais au milieu on a
un petit bouton garder qui est un peu
plus marqué là qu'on sent vraiment foot
doit pour le différencier des deux
autres et bien c'est bon pour devenir
active et google assistant alors
franchement j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre pourquoi alors il ya un côté
pratique on peut dire effectivement par
la google c'est de l'assistant je suis
d'accord mais vous pouvez la voir
exactement de la même manière avec la
fonction oki google donc pourquoi
ajouter un bouton ici alors que vous
l'avez à la voix
bah écoutez je sais pas pour moi ça
vient rajouter un petit bouton trop
après je vais tout de suite on le sent
sous le doigt on comprend vraiment
qu'elle écoute un peu granuleux sur le
doigt sa force wade semble un petit peu
son doigt pour le bouton pour la libé
potins de soi monte un peu trop son
doigt pour trouver un bouton de volume
c'est un point de détail mais voyez je
comprends pas pourquoi ce bouton est là
bon on passe rapidement là dessus de
tout est absolument rien rien de tous
les côtés si ici on a une petite prise
jack ça c'est vachement bien vous voir
écouter au casque en jack ça c'est cool
et vous avez sur le dessous de la
recharge en usb c'est ça c'est aussi
très très bien ici un haut parleur mono
il pèse à peine plus de 200 grammes 200
grammes pour tout vous dire il existe en
deux couleurs ici c'est la aurora blue
par soudainement j'aime beaucoup avec
ses reflets il ya également la island
silver que je n'ai pas ici côté design
if hell taf
moi personnellement j'aime bien la prise
en main est assez bonne en est sûre en
grand format mais rien de bien
révolutionnaire par rapport à l'ensemble
des smartphones du marché
c'est un standard ça fonctionne c'est
bien on le tient bien à demain de
préférence que vous avez quand même un
grand écran est justement l'écran
parlons-en
ici on trouve un écran de 6,55 pouces et
une dali psc du lcd attention par contre
si on a pas de résolution full hd on a
une résolution hd plus 1600 par 720
pixels à 267 pixels par pouce vous
pouvez venir un petit peut paramétrer
votre écran par défaut il vous le met en
temps par défaut justement à 7500 kelvin
ok ça marche les tons chauds joli tout
de suite il ya un côté un peu violine
verdâtre que je trouve pas terrible je
vous le déconseille à des tons froids à
8500 kelvin que je vous conseille pas
nécessairement rester au 7500 c'est pour
moi ce qui marchera le mieux ici qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
possibilités pour avoir un thème sombre
si vous le souhaitez comme on n'est pas
ici sur un écran oled le fait d'avoir un
tel monde ça ne va pas venir
vous permettent de gagner au niveau de
l'autonomie bon on repart à l'autonomie
avec le temps parce que déjà les bacs
avec une batterie de 5000 millions
terreur vous avez de quoi faire et
largement pour regarder votre contenu
sur youtube ça fera très très bien le
tas on va voir ici effectivement le
petit poisson les ont révélés conan
alors attention en tout cas connaître
ici c'est que si vous voulez regarder du
contenu sur netflix disney + et
compagnie et bien vous n'avez pas
pouvoir le regarder en full hd
c'est une question de droit puisque ici
vous avez le white vine l3 permettra
d'avoir une lecture uniquement sd et pas
en full hd voilà ça c'est un petit peu
le regret donc si vous voulez acheter ce
smartphone pour être du contenu de bonne
qualité sur netflix mick hannah les
compagnies et bien c'était pas là-dessus
qu'il faut partir à côté de ça pour
l'utiliser pour les différents réseaux
sociaux sur un smartphone qui fonctionne
bien qui fera le boulot sans en faire
trop mais c'est ce qu'on va rechercher
une fois de plus sur un smartphone à 199
euros 99
concernant la partie audio vous avez un
petit haut parleur mono qui se situe à
un peu profité de l'expérience aux
castes si vous le souhaitez cela vous
aurez est la meilleure expérience en
branchant votre casque lorsque vous
l'écoutez directement comme ça bon le
son est assez médium une fois de plus on
est sur un smartphone il coûte pas non
plus y praille prat cher ça il faut le
savoir
elle n'a pas un niveau dingue le fond et
pas extrêmement fort ouais la suite
complètement à fond
bien que ça reste cohérent il fallut
that has not found de fria y fractales
sans fin car on sait que sur un
smartphone dans cette gamme de prix on
va pas s'attendre à voir quelque chose
de très performant on s'est avéré une
fois de plus on est dans cette gamme de
prix
un peu moins de 200 euros et dans
l'entré deux guerres ici le soc c'est un
média texte ainsi 1765 oct à coeur on a
4 gigas bram +128 giga de stockage qu'on
peut augmenter grâce à une carte microsd
jusqu'à 256 jk bon ça c'est plutôt bien
et à noter que vous avez double sim plus
carte microsd ça vous fait en tout 3 ce
lot donc ça c'est vraiment cool
maintenant l'un des points forts qui est
mis en avant par wikio là dessus c'est
sa grosse batterie de 5000 millions
paire eur alors je sais pas si vous êtes
coutumier des smartphones et des
smartphones dans l'entrée et dans le
milieu de gamme
c'est bien souvent l'argument qui est
mis en avant en disant on n'a t'elle pas
le smartphone le plus rapide au monde un
smartphone le plus endurant avec la plus
grosse batterie c'est un gros focus
marketing qui est fait là dessus et il
nous annonce une autonomie allant
jusqu'à trois jours et demi
certifié par smart driver 3 jours et
demi ces données selon un protocole
d'utilisation du smartphone est-ce que
vous maintenant vous allez arriver
jusqu'à trois jours et demi en fonction
de votre utilisation c'est pas
nécessairement sur ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce smartphone là vous garderez
hi mom deux jours très facilement vous
allez pouvoir en faire un peu plus mais
bien évidemment ça dépend du fait plus
de vous de vos usages si vous êtes
beaucoup dessus
si vous jouez beaucoup alors je voulais
beaucoup oui vous n'allez pas faire
tomber dessus les jeux les plus
performants les jo les plus puissants
mais pour plein de petits jeux de dupes
les stores et bien vous avez de quoi
vous amuser donc ça s'est vraiment bien
donc une fois de plus à l'avenir jouer
sur l'autonomie si vous jouez beaucoup
si vous regardez beaucoup de vidéos sur
youtube et des vidéos de monsieur
heureux c'est encore mieux et bien à ce
moment là il se peut que votre autonomie
elle diminue et déjà avec 8,5 millions
terreur vous êtes tranquille et ça c'est
extrêmement rassurant alors ici pas de
recharge rapide mais vous accable de la
recharge ici en usb c'est une fois de
plus assez cool côté os en tourne sur
android 10 avec une surcouche rico avec
quelques petites fonctionnalités dédiées
aux icônes et ya rien de bien dingo
pouvait venir cacher le not capture
d'écran à trois doigts mais sinon on
trouve vraiment les grands basique
d'android ça fonctionnera très bien vous
avez votre tiroir d'application avec
toutes vos applis qui sont planqués là
vous pouvez la retrouver également sur
cauterets voyez ça marche bien une fois
de plus je le dis ça j'aime bien chaud
c'est vraiment extrêmement malin
maintenant et c'est le deuxième promesse
faite par ce smartphone on a ici quatre
capteurs photo on a un capteur principal
de 48 mégapixels hong hanh ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et on a deux
petites caméras une macro de 5
mégapixels et 1,14 profondeur de 2
mégapixels et j'ai pas plus
d'informations à vous communiquer sur
les ouvertures tandis qu'à l'avant
justice y est bien une petite caméra de
celle fille de 8 mégapixels alors moi
toi que j'ai bien aimé c'est l'interface
parce que l'interface
écoutez je trouve plutôt pas mal et as
intuitive on va pas venir sans bétail
des fioritures
ici on a un mode nuit un mode vidéo pour
filmer en vidéo si vous souhaitez mais
je vous le conseille pas nécessairement
on filme en 1080p à 30 images par
seconde est pas extraordinaire le mode
photo qui est plutôt pas mal et ce que
j'aime bien c'est voyez on va changer
ici on passe dans l' ultra grand-angle
et on peut venir regarder très
facilement venir nous mais c'est tout
doux et après hop on appuie là on passe
sur l' ultra grand-angle on dessine mode
portrait cloud arrière plan vous allez
dire par là mais très puis ensuite
quelques petits effets pour mieux vous
faire une tête de chien compagnie ce que
vous voulez lycée votre peau on va venir
vous amuser avec ça ça pour moi c'est
gadget vous valait un peu plus loin
qu'un mode super macro je vous montre le
résultat dans quelques instants
bon tout ce qui va être slow motion
professionnels time lapse et photo
dynamique pour moi ça on oublie
voyons voir résultats photos alors là on
est sur le capteur principal 146
mégapixels dans l'idée c'est pas mal le
seul chose que je vais venir
prochainement ici c'est toute la gestion
du hd
on le voit là les nuages on a absolument
aucun détail c'est quand même bien cramé
on voit légèrement ici en haut à gauche
mais sans le reste derrière on le voit
et on le verra dans des photos un peu
plus loin à côté de ça les couleurs sont
pas mal et pour faire des photos
souvenirs on aura quelque chose qui est
cohérent dès qu'on passe sur l'ultra
grand temps que c'est moins bien tout de
suite c'est beaucoup plus terne et ont
plus de ça c'est quand même relativement
déformant la gestion du hdr non plus pas
très très bonne on le voit on a très
très peu de détails dans les nuages et
c'est quand même relativement cramé mais
c'est tout ce qui me dérange moins ici
c'est vraiment ce côté eh bien voyez les
couleurs sont tout de suite très très
terne et c'est pas terrible terrible
lorsqu'on vient zoomer sur votre caméra
principale eh bien on a un zoom
numérique on va perdre en qualité alors
ne venez pas trop mais on peut
légèrement honneur qu'on peu plus
rapproché les privilégiés de choix venir
vous rapprocher pour venir zoomer avec
ce smartphone la caméra principale c'est
la même chose des couleurs seront pas
mal au niveau de l'art du soldat
fonctionnent les ombres on est ok par
contre derrière variés que toute la
gestion du hdr avec le ciel et bien
c'est cramé on sait pas si si c'est un
bâtiment haut à gauche mélange avec un
nuage
on s'y perd un petit peu et c'est
vraiment le gros point de reproches qui
devrait faire sur cette caméra
principale l'ultra grand angle c'est la
même chose c'est très déformant regarder
on n'a pas tant que l'immeuble est bien
c'est la tour de pise elle se penche
elle se tord c'est une fois de plus
ternes et variés c'est un peu dommage
la caméra de celle fille sera peu près
correct ça sera pas trop trop mal une
fois de plus sa gestion de la page
dynamique un peu complexe derrière avec
cet immeuble qui est beaucoup trop blanc
on perd un peu en détail on a un peu de
bruit sur l'image notamment au niveau du
visage et un côté un peu terre mais une
fois de plus sur un smartphone à 199.99
qui vient va pas non peut venir lui
demander la lune
moi je suis pas trop fan de maquereau en
général je vais pas dire je suis bluffé
par la macro mais ça reste quand même
très cohérent et on sort des choses qui
sont assez rigolote voyez pour le fait
de capter le petit insecte ici on se met
à quatre centimètres de distance et ont
un truc est quand même assez juste c'est
pas trop mal le mode portrait le
détourage est un peu hasardeux au niveau
des doigts mais ça fera le tas quand
vous avez quelques clichés
s'il a un peu plus de mal au niveau de
la couleur pour me dire bien des tours
et et là j'ai perdu un bout de crâne
bon la photo ne dit par contre j'ai fait
des photos j'ai fait les petitesses mais
bon vous
c'est pas fait pour ça la question est
ce que je trouve ce week au view 5 plus
intéressants et bien je pense qu à
199.99 wiko fait une proposition qui
intéressant une fois de plus dans cette
gamme de prix on va pas s'attendre à
avoir des specs de dingue on va pas
s'attendre à voir des écrans dingue
le bémol que je vais avoir au niveau de
l'expérience multimédia c'est qu'on ne
puisse pas cadets du contenu sur netflix
my canal et consorts en full hd
c'est dommage parce que si ça fait
partie vraiment vos usages et bien ça
peut être un petit peu rédhibitoire
l'autonomie est vraiment cool et ça
c'est un des gros points forts de
smartphones est une fois de plus je vous
dis c'est souvent un argument marketing
de poids dans l'entrée milieu de gamme
la wii qu a vraiment réussi sa copie le
design se tient par rapport à ce qu'on
peut attendre une faute plus de
smartphones dans l'entrée de gamme car
ici ce smartphone vous intéresse je
voulais dire coûte 199 euros 99 et si
vous voulez économiser encore un petit
peu au niveau du budget bien vous avez
le view 5 qui vous coûtera 179 euros 99
avec 3 giga de ram et 64 go de stockage
on va venir forcément perdre ici en
fluidité et surtout au niveau du
stockage 64 giga de stockage aujourd'hui
je suis un peu moins convaincus olic au
travail vraiment à se battre face à une
concurrence qui est extrêmement féroce
ils sont toujours là ils se bagarrent
leurs produits se tiennent sans
cohérence sont sympas donc s'il vous
intéresse je voulais gagner évidemment
un lien en bas dans la description et
comme beaucoup d'autres marques le fond
et bien oui qu'on est venu avec des
accessoires on va voir ici un petit
smartphone vous prenez vous glissez
votre petit héroïco à l'intérieur ça
viendra vous protégez votre smartphone
et vous avez également un pack avec une
petite coque de protection transparente
et vous avez également un petit
protection d'écran que vous venez
installé dessus
last but not least comme on dit du côté
du outre-atlantique et outre-manche
eh bien ils vous proposent ça c'est le
oui tchèque vibe en fait ce sont des
petits haut parleurs et je trouve ça
rigolo
regardez comme ça et hop vous pouvez
venir ouvrir alors il se connecte très
très facilement en bluetooth à wayne
smith de mets de la musique
partout je j'ai mes deux haut parleurs
comme ça je peux sans me mettre comme ça
les ferait une seule source
mais j'ai la stéréo avec tyson et en
plus de ça veut dire mettre des petites
lumières intérieures regarder voilà
comme ça je me fais de la luminothérapie
je mets de la musique à la maison a vous
de me dire maintenant vous ce que vous
pensez de ce nouveau smartphone de wiko
le view 5 plus est ce qu'il pourrait
vous intéresser
il faut tout ça en bas en commentaire
oui quoi toujours dans la place et il en
est de même de la musique cette fois ci
donc ça c'est un très bon point a vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez en
barque au mental je trouve extrêmement
rapidement continuer à parler tech vient
évidemment de smartphones et puis
pourquoi pas un peu de lui aussi allé
très vite
ciao